indien meine damen und herren wenn ich
das höre denke ich an leckeres essen an
farbenpracht an chaotische städte yoga
kann die bollywood und an informatik
mein heutiger gast aber hat ganz andere
assoziationen auch und die reue ist so
etwas wie das schlechte gewissen indiens
und vielleicht der ganzen welt immer
wieder zeigt sie wie grausam irland ist
und wieviel unterdrückung es nach wie
vor gibt das tat sie bereits vor 20
jahren mit ihrem weltbestseller der gott
der kleinen dinge
und auch jetzt wieder mit ihrem zweiten
roman der pünktlich zur 70 jahr feier
der indischen unabhängigkeit erscheint
das ministerium des äußersten glücks und
die räume ganz herzlich willkommen ja
indien hat gefeiert am 15 august 70
jahre unabhängigkeit von der britischen
kolonialmacht haben sie auch gefeiert
auch noch einen ton habe ich nicht was
ich denke wir haben noch einen langen
weg bevor wir sagen können dass alle
leute in indien von allen formen des
kolonialismus befreit sind
diese unabhängigkeit das sind wir uns
nicht bewusst hat war auch damals eine
trennung das ist etwas das wenige wissen
und zwar wurde es gab indien und
pakistan wurde getrennt wir sehen was
auf eine karte und zwar in ein west und
ein ostpakistan das muslimische ist und
indien mehrheitlich hinduistischen und
aus dem ost pakistan wurde dann 1971
bangladesch das sehen wir auch auf
dieser karte
wir schauen kurz rein in diese
unabhängigkeitsfeier und nach zurück 70
jahre was das für die leute bedeutet hat
damals diese unabhängigkeit aber auch
diese trennung
ein martialischer grossert gilt
premierminister narendra modi auftritt
an der unabhängigkeitsfeier der
kriegerische ton in welt auch modi am
anfang seiner rede sei es auf dem meer
oder an land sei es im cyberspace oder
im weltall indien kann sich in jeder art
und weise verteidigen und es kann denen
die zuversicht nehmen die dem land
schaden wollen
gleich zwei länder können sich
angesprochen fühlen einmal china seit
wochen gibt es spannungen im himalaya
jeder behauptet die truppen des anderen
besetzten fremdes territorium
zweitens natürlich pakistan brennpunkt
ist hier vor allem kaschmir
seit der unabhängigkeit von beiden
ländern beansprucht überhaupt pakistan
mohammed ali jinnah machte es unabhängig
janeiro regierte als erster premier den
rest indiens es folgte ein massenexodus
einer der größten der geschichte
millionen hindus und sikhs verließen in
den nächsten jahren pakistan umgekehrt
migrierten millionen muslime weg aus
indien 10 bis 15 millionen menschen
verloren ihre heimat
überschattet wurde das ganze durch
furchtbare massaker wohl eine million
menschen starben durch interreligiösen
terror zehntausende frauen vergewaltigt
unzählige familien getrennt auch indiens
gegenwart ist nicht frei von problemen
moody's forcierte hin die politik hat
das potenzial die gesellschaft zu
spalten
ja premierminister narendra modi seit
drei jahren im amt
wer ist dieser mann ist ein mann der er
2014 premierminister wurde war er
während sieben jahren chief minister des
bundesstaats gut
grundsätzlich das problem ist wenn es um
die schaffung von indien pakistan und
bangladesch geht sprechen wir von einer
teilung
wir sprechen aber nie über die gewalt
der zwangs eingliederung denn es gab
damals rund 500 unabhängige
fürstenzimmer die sich zwischen indien
und pakistan entscheiden in einem von
ihnen in kaschmir dauert der konflikt
bis heute und auch in den bundesstaaten
im nordosten indiens seit 1947 verging
kein einziger tag an dem die indische
armee nicht im landesinnern gegen die
eigenen leute eingesetzt wurde
die ist mitglieder heute mächtigsten
organisationen in indien sie heißt es
ist keine politische partei die bdp die
regierungspartei ist der politische
flügel dieser völkischen kader
organisation genannt
wir haben hier alles was ist dieser gruß
wahrscheinlich diese radikal
hinduistischen karte organisation und
was was was ist das ziel dieser
organisation mutti ist er mitglied modi
und eine reihe seiner minister sind
mitglieder wie auch ein ehemaliger
premierminister dazu gehört der ares es
entstand in den 1920 er jahren und
glaubt an die idee einer hindu nation
sagt indien sei ein hindu staats oder
habe eine hindu mehrheit stimmt das
nicht
es ist ein land das aus minderheiten
besteht
es gibt sechs christen buddhisten und
natürlich die weltweit größte moslem
kooperation
außer indonesien vielleicht wurde seit
der 1920 er jahren nach dem vorbild des
europäischen faschismus aufgebaut
viele seiner ideologen haben offen
gesagt dass die muslime für indien das
sein was die juden für deutschland und
sogar heute zum beispiel 2002 als motiv
minister war gab es in seinem
bundesstaat ein massaker an muslime
es war nicht das erste massaker an
muslimen in indien aber es war das erste
im zeitalter der waffen
das erste das ideologisch gerechtfertigt
wurden die leute dass man sich nicht
entschuldigt hat und heute ertönt oft
sie skandieren
es ist nicht einfach der iss sie haben
viele dubiose bürgerwehren so dass man
die organisation als solche nicht
gesetzlich verantwortlich machen kann
aber er verbreitet das heißt für muslime
gibt es nur einen platz den friedhof
oder pakistan der ss mit
hunderttausenden von freiwilligen hat
eigene schulen verlagshäuser
sozialarbeiter er engagiert sich in der
bekehrung
sie nennen es bekehrung zum heute
verbreitet er eine stimmung die dazu
führt dass banden und bürgerwehren
muslime und unberührbare zu tode prügeln
gestützt auf gerüchte dass sie
rindfleisch essen oder kühle
transportieren minderheiten werden
detoniert
warum erlebt diese nationalistische
hinduistische bewegung die weg von der
viel halten möchte ich hin zu einer
einheit gerade jetzt so ein aufschwung
was ist der grund dafür
wir müssen verstehen dass es seit den
1920 er jahren im anzug war es musste
zwangsläufig so weit kommt als motto
gewählt wurde gab es das ganze gerede
von endlich nach hunderten von jahren
ist die herrschaft der hindus
zurückgekehrt und nicht wie die leute
bringen modi und schaut durcheinander
es ist aber nicht das gleiche ist ein
außenseiter
während wir hier ein system haben dass
alle demokratischen institutionen
unterwandert hat insbesondere die medien
es gibt eine verschmelzung von einer art
neuem liberalem unternehmenskapital und
diesem system
heute ist die lage sehr kritisch weil
die wirtschaft die der neu geschaffenen
mittelschicht 1 der lösung versprach die
begeisterung der 1990 er jahre schlägt
in panik wir haben ein sogenannt
beschäftigungs freies wachstum aber
jetzt geht sogar dieses wachstum
drastisch zurück
nein seit kurzem geht das zurück dieses
wachstum hatte ohnehin einen hohen preis
hunderttausende bauern die sich
umgebracht haben millionen von menschen
die von ihrem land vertrieben
die aussenquartiere von delhi gleichen
irgendwelchen mittelalterlichen orten
fabrikarbeiter buchstäblich wie im
konzentrationslager leben
sie haben nicht einmal genügend geld um
zu überleben
sie leben unter unerträglichen
bedingungen
ihre arbeitsstunden sind unbegrenzt man
hat also eine situation mit einer krise
die von unten hoch kommt und auf diesen
wirtschaftlichen abschwung trifft und
alle wut richtet sich nach unten
gegen minderheiten gegen dahlitz gegen
menschen die schon unterdrückt sind so
wird die frustration ausgelegt sie
sprechen schon auch diese probleme an
mit denen sie sich in ihren romanen aber
auch in ihren essays beschäftigen die in
euren ungerechtigkeiten ungleichheiten
missstände darüber brauchen wir gleich
noch sprechen mich interessiert ist
nochmal die großwetterlage global
gesehen weil wir erleben ja also etwas
wie eine sehnsucht nach diesen
autoritären persönlichkeiten hin zu
einer identität politik ob das bei putin
ist bei erdogan ist bei trump ist bei
moody's
warum hat das mit der globalisierung zu
tun was ist der grund dafür
ich glaube es hat etwas mit
globalisierung zu tun
weil wenn sie versuchen eine situation
zu schaffen in der sich eine art plastik
und einheits kultur über die welt
ausbreitet und dieses ganze thema
identität das gleichzeitig wichtig und
unwichtig ist wo leute so
auseinanderdividiert werden dass sie nie
in frage stellen was für eine
weltordnung dahinter steckt je schwerer
die krise von wirtschaft und umwelt ist
öfter das geschieht in indien etwa
können sie einen konflikt zwischen zwei
kasten beobachten oder einen konflikt
zwischen hindus und muslimen
manche man hat dieser konflikt damit gar
nichts zu tun sondern es geht um das
schrumpfen der ressourcen um die
unmöglichkeit schon eigenen boden zu
leben wenn der grundwasserspiegel sinkt
wie kann man diese ressourcen
zurückfordern indem man von seiner
identität gebrauch macht und schon die
gesellschaft in indien ein wir wissen
historisch die grausamste soziale
hierarchie errichtet hat die eine
menschliche gesellschaft überhaupt
erfinden kann
das heißt die seitlich verordnet ist das
kasten darüber werden wir gleich noch
sprechen wenn wir über hindu hindus und
muslime sprechen den konflikt den es
schon sehr sehr lange gibt in indien
dann spielt auch kaschmir eine große
rolle wir haben das gesehen im film aber
er spielt auch in ihrem buch eine große
rolle im ganzen zweiten teil kann man
sagen dass indien dieses trauma der
trennung immer noch nicht verarbeitet
hat und zeigt sich dass gerade jetzt in
kaschmir
man bezeichnet den konflikt in kaschmir
als die unvollendete angelegenheit der
teilung
wissen sie ich habe wirklich ein problem
mit diesem begriff teilung weil er
suggeriert es habe einmal ein ganzes
gebiet
dieses ganze sei in kleinere teile
aufgeteilt was aber war das ganze was
war diese alte indische oder hindu
zivilisation die sich selber als land
bezeichnet in wahrheit waren es die
briten die auf einer karte abstecken was
indien ist es war ein land das von den
briten geschaffen wurde und wie ich
gesagt habe
schließlich gab es viel anpassung und
daraus entstehende gewalt man könnte zum
beispiel argumentieren
der konflikt in kaschmir sei eine folge
der erzwungenen eingliederung
und nicht der teil schwer war ein
fürstentum ein fürstentum mit einer
muslimischen bevölkerungsmehrheit und
einem hindu herrscher der sich in der
tat erst in letzter sekunde dafür
entschied indien beizutreten
das war der auslöser des konflikts weil
es schon vor 1947 eine bewegung seiner
untertanen gegeben hatte die den könig
stürzen wollte es schließlich wird das
dann immer in religiöse begriffe
gegossen so in wirklichkeit ist der
konflikt in kaschmir ein konflikt den
beide indien und pakistan am leben
erhalten möchten weil er ihre politik im
eigenen land stärkt ich glaube nicht
dass es irgendeinen beweis dafür gibt
dass sich die kashmiris pakistan
anschließen wollen
ich glaube die mehrheit spricht von asa
die freiheit heute ist es ein äußerst
komplizierte konflikt eine partei im
ganzen konflikt sehen sie irgendeine
lösung befragen bevor man von einer
lösung sprechen kann sollte man sich
fragen ob überhaupt jemand eine will im
moment sicher seid die neue regierung an
der macht ist dominiert der wunsch
jegliche möglichkeit für irgend welche
art von gespräch zu ersticken
früher gab es die alte schlaue
intelligente staatskunst wo man leute
hatte die immer noch in der lage waren
miteinander zu sprechen
und zumindest den status quo aufrecht zu
halten
aber heute haben wir die situation dass
dieser mittelweg weggebrannt wurde hat
die dichteste militärische besetzung
gewählt
sie haben dort rund 600.000 indische
soldaten jetzt ist es fast wie eine
konfrontation
bei der am anfang in den 1990 er jahren
waren es einzelne militante die gegen
die armee kämpft sich aber jetzt haben
wir eine militante bevölkerung die mit
truppen konfrontiert ist es ist also
eine äußerst gefährliche situation
sie beschäftigen sich wirklich mit
mitkriegen mit katastrophen mit
missständen ungerechtigkeiten
trotzdem steht in ihrem neuen roman im
titel das wort glück können sie
überhaupt noch glücklich sein wenn sie
sich die ganze zeit mit diesen
ungerechtigkeiten und mit diesem elend
auseinandersetzen
viele leute glauben dass der titel
ministerium des äußersten glücks
satirisch gemeint sei ist es aber nicht
dieses buch ist nicht bloß ein katalog
von horror kriegen disaster und solche
dinge
es handelt von äußerst verletzliche
menschen die in der mitte von all den
menschlichkeit finden die an
ausserordentlichen und ungewöhnlichen
orten poesie musik und glück finden
es handelt ebenso von der liebe wie vom
krieg es handelt von menschen die wissen
das glück keine feste einrichtung ist
und wie man es erkennt wenn man begegnet
und es stimmt die letzten 20 jahre
unterwegs dort wo ich lebe im herzen so
mancher konflikte im gespräch mit
menschen
ich glaube es war james bord wenn der
gesagt hat weshalb glauben die menschen
man müsse traurige lieder traurig singen
und lieder vom glück fröhlich und findet
den komischsten schwarzem humor in
kaschmir die lustigsten witze unter den
geringer kämpfern im wald diese art von
widerstand
die man in den trostlosen wohnungen
politische analysten nicht findet gehirn
für sie diese beiden sehr
unterschiedlichen dinge
der schrecken das elend und die
schönheit irgendwie auch zusammen
das tut sie wirklich ist auf weil sie
mitten im größten grauen schönheit
finden
und inmitten dieser künstlichen billigem
plastik schönheit der fernsehwerbung
finde ich großes grauen sie bieten das
buch ja denn um getröstet
das heißt literatur kann auch trösten
wie macht sie das
das ministerium des äußersten glücks
oder was das betrifft der gott der
kleinen dinge kann nie ein
musikinstrument mit nur einer seite sein
eine geschichte kreieren heißt
mannschaft ein universum man kreiert ein
vielschichtiges universum ein universum
mit wilden straßen und höfen autobahnen
und sackgasse
sie laden den leser ein das ganze zu
begehen wie sie einen reisenden dazu
einladen eine stadt zu erwandern um sie
zu verstehen wenn man ein universum baut
muss man ein ganzes spektrum von
gefühlen von emotionen durchqueren
es darf nicht bloß ein manifest sein
oder eine ideologie getarnt als roman wo
man die protagonisten benutzt wie sie
das mit den figuren auf ihrem
schachbrett
forschungen die verbindung zwischen den
beiden büchern
ich komme mir wie eine art dem wind
gestein vor mit schichten und schicht
manchmal sage ich das ministerium des
äußersten glücks ist nicht bloß eine
stadt sondern eine unterwasserstadt wenn
sie zum ersten mal lesen schwimmen sie
mit den fischen an der oberfläche
nach und nach tauchen sie hinunter
schwimmen mit den fischen in der mitte
und schließlich mit jenen die sich am
meeresgrund ich meine achter vergleich
mit der stadt sie haben ja architektur
studiert auch die ganze architektur das
des buches wenn man das zum ersten mal
liest es ist auch anstrengend das muss
ich sagen aber es lohnt sich man kann
eben genau diese architektur verfolgen
aber sie haben mal gesagt schreiben ist
für sie auch so etwas wie ein gebet das
war nicht interessant warum weil es
diese art von konzentration verlangt
konzentration ein gebet sollte keine
bitte keine forderung und gott sein es
geht und die qualität der konzentration
die man aufbringt für mich ist das
größte glück in meinem leben wenn ich
eine aufgabe habe die all meine
fähigkeiten in anspruch nimmt
all meine stärken meine ganze
konzentration sowohl körperlich wie
geistig
meinem herzen mit allem und schon das
allein egal was andere über das buch
denken oder nicht denken
allein die möglichkeit dass in ihrem
leben tun zu können ist ein see und was
viele leser überrascht und begeistert
ist diese bilderreiche sprache schon im
ersten buch der gott der kleinen dinge
da ist auch schon sehr viel
gesellschaftskritik drin aber sind diese
metaphern und bilder die sie erbringen
die sehr kühl sind zum teil auch diese
metaphern
was ist für sie die die funktion oder
den wert einer guten metapher wenn ich
versuchen sollte das zu beurteilen
müsste ich eine ökonomen seien
ich weiß nichts über wert ich bin
einfach so und sehe die dinge so
verstehe sie
sie denken in diesen vergleichen
metapher ist auch immer einfach war ich
ja es ist ein vergleich
aber es ist irgendwie auch ein gedicht
nicht wahr es ist wieder unterschied ob
man einem tanz zuschaut oder ob man die
bewegungen des tänzers grafisch
darstellen wenn man etwas oder mithelfer
einfach beschreiben will ist es manchmal
der knochen das gerät während die
metapher den fluss oder die
unmittelbarkeit das unerklärliche von
etwas ausdrückt beim jesus so was
verändert achtung machen es sehr
erhellend wenn man etwas besser versteht
wenn man es mit einem anderen
gegen vergleichen kann ich habe den
eindruck in ihrer literatur geht es im
wesentlichen darum die außenseiter ins
zentrum zu rücken und zu zeigen dass
diese klassifizierung nicht halten und
so weiter es gibt eine wunderschöne
stelle in dem buch der gott der kleinen
dinge über bananen marmelade die
verboten ist weil sie eben zu dünn sei
für marmelade und zu dick für charlie
sie habe schreiben sie eine zweideutige
nicht klassifizierbar konsistenz und die
ganze familie ist eine
familiengeschichte der geht es auch so
die hat schwierigkeiten mit
klassifikation sie schreiben sie alle
fürchten an den gesetzten herum die
festlegen wer wie geliebt werden sollte
und wie sie an den gesetzen die
großmutter zu groß mitternacht ein onkel
zu onkel metern zur mitte wo sie in
zukunft machen wir laden zu marmelade
und schnee zu schädigen und sie selbst
sind ja auch schwer zu klassifizieren
sag ich jetzt mal einen an führung zum
schluss zeichen
ihre mutter ist syrische christin aus
kerala im süden indiens der vater eines
bengalen sie wuchsen dann aber auch bei
der großmutter auf ist dass diese innere
diversität ist das für sie eine
bereicherung oder kann das auch eine
eine herausforderung sein wenn sie das
von außerhalb der lokalen indischen
gesellschafts perspektive betrachten was
soll weltbewegend daran sein dass meine
mutter eine syrische christen ist und
mein vater in das sollte kein großes
problem sein aber es ist trotzdem 1
wegen des kastensystems weil nur fünf
leute oder noch weniger außerhalb ihrer
kaste heirat wegen wie sie beschrieben
haben anfang anarchie und gandhi und
yoga und all dem in wirklichkeit
herrscht das gegenteil von
anarchie gibt es im stadt aber in
wirklichkeit ist es eine gesellschaft
die im eisernen gitter des kastensystems
lebt meine mutter ist eine syrische
christen mein vater war ein bengalischer
hindu sie ließen sich scheiden
und so wuchs ich in diesem kleinen dorf
auf wo man mir schon als ich sehr klein
war klar machte dass ich nicht zu dieser
gemeinschaft gehöre wissen noch was
nicht das gleiche war wie wenn ich eine
unberührbare gewesen und deshalb
unterdrückt worden wäre wie die dalits
in indien unterdrückt werden
was einfach nur schrecklich ist aber
sogar sie haben eine gemeinschaft nicht
wahr
sie gehören zusammen während ich zu
niemandem gehört und sie versuchen die
ganze zeit herauszufinden weshalb das so
sein soll
natürlich war diese art von nachteil ein
segen für eine schrift stellung ich
glaube dadurch wurde ich schon als
fünfjährige zur schriftstellerin in dem
ich versuchte eine gesellschaft zu
betrachten in deren mitte ich lebte zu
der ich aber nicht gehören würde
diesen blick von außen aber auch diese
vielfalt von stimmen
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt über das kastensystem
gesprochen
die dalits kampf vor die unberührbaren
wir haben dazu einen grafik die dieses
unglaublich komplizierte kastensystem
etwas versucht zu vereinfachen
es gibt vier haupt kasten so genannte
warmes übersetzt heißt aus farben ganz
oben stehen die brahmanen die priester
gelehrten dann kommen fürsten krieger
bauern kaufleute knechte und so weiter
und keine eigene haupt gäste haben eben
diese dalits die mit einer gewissen
unreinheit soweit ich weiss auch immer
assoziiert werden
die müssten zum beispiel auch gut
anderer leute wegputzen wir haben noch
dazu ein war ein paar schreckliche
bilder
und dieses system ist heute noch
relevant für die partner waren für die
berufsfahrer wir sehen hier die bilder
schrecklich ich frage mich aus der
distanz
wie kann sich so ein system
bis heute halten nicht schockiert in der
tat dass die welt so lange braucht um zu
verstehen
aber dieses system das wir hier sehen
heute stand zum beispiel in einem
zeitungsartikel dass mehr leute in
solchen schächten sterben während sie
den code andere leute putzen als
soldaten in kaschmir sogar heute haben
sie immer noch diese system sogar heute
wo jeder sagt indien ist globalisiert es
wächst ist eine supermacht aber ich habe
untersucht wie sich das kastensystem in
diesem neuen kapitalismus statistisch
darstellt und man sieht dass praktisch
jedes größere unternehmen im besitz von
familien ist die man beim jassen die zur
kaste der händler gehören alle wirklich
alle
[Musik]
und wenn sie schon wer die reinigungs
leute sind in den gemeinden beim start
die die abwassersysteme reinigen manche
von ihnen tragen
gesammelten code tatsächlich auf ihrem
kopf sie sind alle da alle aber das
kassensystem und der kapitalismus haben
sich zu einem giftigen system
verschmolzen
wissen sie machen was mich überrascht
was ich dann nicht verstehe ist was der
präsident der gegenwärtige auch ein da
lebt ist auch ein unberührbare und zwar
hat war es gab es das davor auch schon
wie kann das sein
der präsident ist ein zeremoniell
er hat keine wirkliche macht überhaupt
nicht wir hatten in der vergangenheit
auch schon einen dalit als präsidentin
die ordner reihen am ende holt trick der
ganze trick mit dem präsidentenamt ist
dass man immer einen präsidenten hat der
trainer wenn die six wasser kreiert
werden folgt ein zig als präsidentin
frauen präsident ein dalit präsident das
ist das schaufenster mit dem man das
scheinwerferlicht davon fern hält das
wirklich passiert jetzt wenn wir an
indien denken spielt man hat man die
auch immer eine große rolle und sie
bringen in enge verbindung mit diesem
kastensystem aber bevor wir über diese
verbindung sprechen möchten wir noch
kurz diesen mythos kann die noch uns
einmal zu gemüte führen mit ein paar
bildern am zweiten oktober 1869 war
indien indes jene man geboren der ist
zur unabhängigkeit führen sollte
mohan das gandhi sohn eines ministers
des kleinstaates probanden angehöriger
der hindu kaste der kaufleute erstmals
richteten sich die kameras der
britischen wochenschau auf ihn als er
1920 seinen öffentlichen kampf gegen die
britische herrschaft begann
es war der kampf ohne waffen erstes ziel
der wirtschaftlichen boykott gegen
britische waren unabhängigkeit der
einheimischen textilindustrie durch
häusliches spinnen bereits 1893 hatte
gandhi in london zum advokaten
ausgebildet in südafrika seine
politische laufbahn als führer der
indischen einwanderer begonnen
unter dem einfluss der indischen idee
des amc das heißt des nicht verletzen
der bergpredigt und der lehrer tolstojs
hatte er hier den passiven widerstand
gegen entrichtende gesetze organisiert
doch in südafrika wie in indien kam es
immer wieder gegen den willen und die
lehre gandhis zu gewaltsamen
ausschreitungen
es ist leichter die unterdrückten massen
zu gewalt aufzurufen schreibt kann die
in seiner geschichte meiner experimente
mit der wahrheit als sie zu disziplin
und gewaltlosem widerstand anzuhalten
gandhi wählte den schwierigeren weg
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wirtschaftlicher boykott nicht
beteiligung an institutionen der
britischen verwaltung bürgerlicher
ungehorsam
dies waren die mittel mit denen dann die
das ziel der unabhängigkeit erreichen
wollte
ja und sie sagen jetzt dieser kämpfer
für die unabhängigkeit mit ohne gewalt
der sei eigentlich ein verfechter das
kastenwesen gewesen und sie schreiben
sogar ein heiliger des status quo
das müssten sie erläutern es ist sehr
schwierig in ein paar wenigen minuten
darüber etwas zu sagen weil das was man
sagt verantwortungsvoll sein muss ich
habe darüber einen langen essay
geschrieben mit dem titel für dr die
saints der sich mit der debatte befasste
zwischen gandhi und seinem laut
stärksten gegner am bfd randaliert war
und heute von den dalits verehrt wird
in indien werden sie im haus eines armen
einem bild von gandhi beginnen
sie finden ein bild von am bett ich
versuche mich so kurz wie möglich zu
halten aber ich möchte dass die leute
darüber lesen
alles was ich schreibe ist keine
interpretation sondern ein zitat aus den
gesammelten werken von jahrgang
ich würde sagen es ist eine der größten
mythen und verfälschungen die es gibt
damit will ich nicht sagen kann dieser
kein herausragender mann er war ein
faszinierender politiker und er hatte
eine bestimmte vision die ich
respektiere
sogar heute ich versuche also nicht ihn
zu dem sie aber beim thema kastensystem
beim thema rasse und beim thema frauen
war er total rückwärts gewandt die
meisten leute haben wir wissen aus
richard evans film der wirklichkeit
korrekt ist
gandhi hielt daran fest dass das
kastensystem der geniestreich der hindu
zivilisation sei er wollte dass die
symbolik der unberührbarkeit
verschwindet aber er glaubte nicht an
ihren rechtsanspruch
er glaubte nicht dass sie das recht
hätten sich selber zu vertreten
er sagte immer ich werde sie vertreten
der größte gandhi mythos in südafrika
besagt dass er den passiven widerstands
kampfes jaguar entwickelt habe um den
rassismus zu bekämpfen
sein erster sieg in südafrika war dass
er bei der post in durban einen dritten
zugang erkämpfte damit sich inder und
schwarzer nicht den gleichen eingang
teilten immer wieder kämpfte er für
separate gefängnisse für indoor weil sie
das gefängnis nicht mit wilden teilen
sollten mit seinem sacra anfing ging es
nicht um rassen gleichheit sondern darum
das verbot aufzuheben das indischen
händlern untersagt ihre geschäfte in
transvaal zu machen es ging nicht um
gefährdete arbeitskräfte oder rechte als
er südafrika verließ ging er als erstes
nach england wo er mieter kaiser erhielt
medaille ausgezeichnet wurde das war die
prestigeträchtigste zivile auszeichnung
die das britische empire jemandem geben
konnte es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich dass
sie jemanden damit ausgezeichnet hätten
der sie bekämpft dann kam er nach indien
am ersten runden tisch zur indischen
frage der in den 1930 er jahren
stattfand wollten die briten die
natürlich ein falsches spiel spielten in
dem sie muslime gegen hindus ausspielten
und versuchten zu teilen und zu
herrschen wie man sagt
die briten verkündeten denn community
ein separates stimmrecht für die
verschiedenen kasten und amt kam nahm
als repräsentanz teil und kämpfte er hat
viel und detailliert darüber geschrieben
weshalb er glaubte dass die dalits für
eine gewisse zeit einen eigenen wahl
preis haben um sich selber zu einer
politischen gesellschaft entwickeln zu
können die eigenständig stimmt für die
ersten schritte in richtung
gleichstellung
aber die briten unterstützten das
anliegen am bett kaufen dann kam kann
die zurück nach indien und begann zu
fasten
fasten bis zum tode dagegen am bett kam
er schließlich zum nachgeben gezwungen
wurde
was als penner packt in die geschichte
eingehen
der heute von vielen dalits als eines
der schrecklichsten dinge gesehen wird
die man eine gemeinschaft antun kann
indem man ihr das recht abspricht sich
selber zu repräsentieren
sehen sie die schriften lesen die immer
wieder schwarze südafrikanische
ureinwohner als kaffer bezeichnet die
immer wieder darauf hinweisen dass inder
der oberschicht echte aria sein und mit
den briten gemeinsame sache machen
müssen wie er bei seiner rückkehr
gegenüber den fabrik besitzern die seine
freunde waren darauf bestand dass er die
gewerkschaften repräsentieren würde es
gibt viel das angaben die bewunderte
salz marsch gehört finde ich zu den
herausragenden stücken von politischem
theater die man sich überhaupt ausdenken
kann
aber es gibt vieles an ihm das
intellektuelle akademiker filmemacher
politiker und die elite verfälscht haben
das ist extrem
heute haben wir ein system das studium
über identität und sozialer hierarchien
ermöglicht ohne dass das kastensystem
erwähnt auch die linke hat sich nicht
ernsthaft mit dem kastensystem geschäft
wir haben vieles zu klären
wir sehen hier noch diesen
dr am witka der selbst jurist war und
dachte indische verfassung
mitgeschrieben hat den sie erwähnen
diesen gegenspiel dazu zumal hat man
dann die in dieser sache ich finde er
war einer der herausragendsten modernen
intellektuellen
viele sagen gandhi musste nach südafrika
und zu entdecken was ungerechtigkeit ist
als david in maras traf wurde gezwungen
auf einem sack tuch auf dem boden am
rand des klassenzimmers zu sitzen
er durfte kein wasser trinken er konnte
sich sein haar nicht schneiden lassen
er musste nicht anderswohin um
ungerechtigkeit zu entdecken er
entdeckte sie dort im dorf in dem er zur
schule gehen und aufwuchs
dieses thema wird unredlich basis
weltweit
ich wollte es jetzt fragen wie bekennt
kämpft man so ein system das sich ja
hunderte tausende lang in gefestigt hat
und in der mentalität der menschen in
den köpfen drin ist aber vielleicht
braucht es zuerst einfach mal raus
klärung und kritik das ist genau was am
bk schlussendlich geht es um den
unterschied zwischen der apartheid
damals in südafrika und der kasten
gesellschaft in das eine war ein
politisches system das andere wird durch
religion gerecht wird
petra sagte dass der hinduismus für
unberührbare eine schreckens kammer sei
und er sagte dass davids zum buddhismus
konvertieren sollten
das ist der ursprung von viel gewalt zb
heute wurde in touristische rechte im
aufwind ist und behauptet indien sei ein
hinduistisches land versucht man
gleichzeitig am pk zu vereinnahmen
weil sie die stimme der dalits das ganze
ist ein system von wahnvorstellungen und
zerrütteten denken
das wahre problem ist aber dass das
kastensystem nicht bloß soziale alltag
ist hass sondern auch als religiöse
praxis gehandhabt wird
es gibt tempel die garlitz nicht
betreten auch heute kommt es vor dass
ein bauer einer höheren kaste des mq
stirbt den kadaver nicht berühren wird
weil die kuh die göttin ist und wann des
todes ist wenn man fleisch ist deshalb
muss man wenn die kuh stirbt einen david
rufen um den kadaver zu reinigen und
dann wird der ausgepeitscht wie es
letztes jahr geschehen ist weil er die
tote kuh abtransportiert wir haben diese
bürgerwehren sogenannte coschützer die
herumziehen und leute auspeitschen und
umbringen weil sie viel handel betreiben
oder kühe transportieren oder fleisch
ist also für mich in der vorbereitung
war schon sehr überraschend wie viel
gewalt es gibt in diesem land nicht nur
ungleichheit sondern auch dieses
gewaltpotenzial gegen frauen gegen
muslime gegen unberührbare wo sehen sie
die wurzel ist dieser gebaut wo was ist
dein grundsätzlich für sie manchmal
denkt man wenn eine kultur die
gewaltlosigkeit zelebriert dann
vielleicht deshalb weil sie so gewaltig
ist schwierig zu sagen
wahrscheinlich braucht es eine
grundlegende soziale und philosophische
untersuchung dieses
aber zum beispiel gewalt an frauen gibt
es heute aus traditionellen wie auch
modernen gründen gast gast immer
bedeutet dass männer einer höheren kaste
losziehen sich einer dalit frau
bemächtigen und sie vergewaltigen
sie dürfen mit einer frau aus der
urbevölkerung machen was sie wollen mit
dem einzug von fernsehen internet- new
economy gibt es jetzt junge frauen die
sich anders definieren die jobs haben
natürlich nur ein kleiner im vergleich
zum heer der verlierer aber es sind
trotzdem fiel die modernisierung junger
frauen ist ebenso ein grund für gewalt
von männern die glauben die kontrolle zu
verlieren
wir haben militärische besetzungen die
eine weitere form von gewalt gegen
frauen zu folgen
es ist wirklich ein land das
zusammengezimmert ist durch militärische
interventionen 65.000 tod in kaschmir
aber entgegen denn wien ackerland
manipur könnten es sogar mehr sein weil
es dort keine bodyguards gibt wie sie in
amerika sagen
seit 1947 ist die indische armee in
nadal 1 statt
wieso rahmen kaschmir
wenn man schaut wer dort lebt gegen wen
wurde die armee eingesetzt
christen adivasi six muslims die
urbevölkerung jetzt das zeigt die
kernaufgabe dieses hinzu staates der
oberen kasten ist alle anderen in
schranken zu halten und wenn man das in
frage stellt wie ich zb dann richten
sich die angriffe nicht gegen mich als
person sondern sie sagen ich sein
oder die journalistin die vor drei oder
vier tagen ermordet wurde
das war weil sie erklärte sie sei keine
hindu-nationalistische man heute im
heutigen indien ermordet nicht mich
interessiert sie sind ja in indien
geblieben nicht so wie andere autoren
sie sind ja in indien geblitzt der in
indien haben sie keine angst wenn sie
hören dass schriftstellerin journalistin
ermordet werden deswegen wissen sie es
gibt in indien auch viele tolle dinge
es gibt großen widerstand gegen all dies
ist ein wichtiges thema es gibt
journalisten und leute die dagegen
ankämpfen
sie haben mich als das gewissen von
indien vorgestellt so fühle ich mich
nicht
es gibt viele wenig ich bin keine
einsame heldin die allein gegen all das
kämpft
[Musik]
vielleicht sollte man auch andere
stimmen
es ist nie gut wenn nur eine einzige
stimme wahrgenommen wird
ich möchte mich weder in dieser rolle
sehen noch so fühlen
ich bin jemand der schon mit der stimme
einer schriftstellerin einer roman
autorin spricht und deshalb ob gut oder
schlecht mit einer einzigartigen stimme
aber mit einer stimme die aus dem herzen
vieler spricht ich bin nicht die einsame
autorin die sich absondert
ich bin die schriftstellerin die im
herzen von alldem liebt deshalb drücke
ich in meinen standpunkten große
solidarität aus natürlich müssen wir
über die dinge reden die wir eben
besprochen was wir dabei aber übersehen
ist die großartigkeit dieses widerstands
die weisheit des widerstands das
verständnis für umweltanliegen die
einsicht darüber was das global
marodierende kapital anrichtet die
verletzlichsten menschen kämpfen und
manchmal gewinnen sie sogar manchmal
wunderbar ein ort den ich liebe nicht
den staat aber den ort als autoren die
alle nuancen versteht weshalb sich
dieses blatt bewegt und warum jene hast
nicht hinunter fällt diese aber schon
sich von nichts zu fürchten ist dumm
taktisch vorgehen verstehen und trotzdem
fortzufahren mit dem was man tut ist
wichtig ich kann wirklich nicht genug
betonen dass ich mich nicht als große
heldin fühle ich bin nicht interessiert
an märtyrertum idiotische wagen
ich liebe das leben ich liebe das
schreiben
ich glaube es ist wichtig alles zu tun
um zu überleben
taktisch vorzugehen und weiterhin zu
streiten spaß zu haben und die
gegenseite zu ärgern und vielleicht
schützt sie die berühmtheit natürlich
auch die sie haben weil das wäre
natürlich eine riesen abschreiben jemand
gegen sie vorgehen würde
es gibt beides
es zieht auch an alle wissen dass jede
klage gegen mich jeder angriff auf mich
einer stellenbewerbung war der regierung
gleich kommt schaut wir haben hier das
angetan
bei der vorstellung meines vorletzten
buchs zum beispiel stürmte eine gruppe
von leuten die das sind jetzt die leiter
der presseabteilung der regierung alles
was mit mir zu tun hat wirkt wie eine
stellenbewerbung und weckt die
aufmerksamkeit von leuten die ich gerne
zum schweigen bringen
ist die app engine of a us man hört
immer in den saal die größte demokratie
der welt mit 1,3 milliarden menschen
für sie ist es eher so etwas wie ein
polizeistaat und sie sagen ist eine
frage der zeit bis indien explodiert
es ist wie eine demokratie für bestimmte
leute eine demokratie für die elite dem
wurde die bedeutung von demokratie auf
die wahlen reden und die leute
beteiligen sich zu millionen
es ist das einzige was ihnen bleibt im
moment auch wenn es eine wahl ist
zwischen kandidaten die keine auswahl
kongress partei der auch gandhi
angehörte regierte indien bis heute ja
die vor modi an der macht war aber
diesem das feld vorbereitet weil sie auf
ihre eigene art von grund auf elitär
ganz und gar den höheren kasten
verpflichtet sie schuf den boden für den
horror den wir heute sehen viele
liberale hatten diesen boden vorbereitet
als einige von uns vor jahren schon die
alarmglocken läuteten und warm
dieses in diesen kreisen die sind extrem
oder die sind links oder das in
panikmache oder die betreiben jetzt aber
erkennt um was es geht
seit den atombombentests von 1999 hat
sich der öffentliche diskurs total
gewandelt
dinge die man früher nicht öffentlich
äußern durfte
man das explizit machen sie sind ja auch
eine große globalisierungs und
kapitalismuskritiker
mich interessiert aber wie gesagt sie
haben jetzt gesagt das
wirtschaftswachstum nimmt ab aber sieben
prozent ist immer noch sehr hoch was
schwebt ihnen denn für eine soziale
marktwirtschaft oder was ganz anderes
als ich begann in die debatte
einzugreifen ging es um die probleme die
sie in einem land wie indien sehen wenn
wichtige infrastrukturen privatisiert
die privatisierung des bildungswesens
die privatisierung des
gesundheitssektors die privatisierung
der elektrizitätsversorgung
man kann mein mann konnte dabei
wenigstens die entstehung einer
mittelklasse beobachten
das war aus sicht europas und des
westens äußerst aufrecht sogar in indien
war es reizvoll weil plötzlich millionen
von menschen teil eines konso marktes
wurden was man nicht so waren die
anderen millionen die ins äußerste elend
getrieben
einige male schutzmaßnahmen heute
beobachtet man dass der arme der
traditionell einen platz in der gunst
hatte im kino wir waren uns immer
bewusst dass wir ein armes land sind
aber jetzt hat man die armen zum
verschwinden gebracht
es gibt keinen platz mehr für sie in den
dörfern in den städten sie haben keinen
platz mehr im vorstellungsvermögen so
haben wir zum beispiel einen bürgerkrieg
über den niemand spricht hat mitten in
indien in den urwäldern im herz
wo millionen von ureinwohnern von ihrem
land vertrieben werden
weil dieses land an private
infrastrukturunternehmen überschrieben
wurde
wie wird das gemacht man überflutet die
wälder mit paramilitärischen kampfdörfer
werden abgebrannt frauen vergewaltigt
und getötet
mann bewaffnet angehörige gewisser
stämme und den eindruck zu erwecken die
urvölker würden sich gegenseitig
bekämpft wie kann man das nicht
kritisieren wenn zehn leute in einem
zimmer sind drei davon sind extrem reich
sg team bestens und sie haben sich ihr
eigenes kleines universum geschaffen
die restlichen sieben sind in großen
schwierigkeiten und wir sprechen über
diese sieben und dann sagen die leute
warum sprichst du nicht über das
positive am gefährlichsten ist der punkt
wie nachhaltig ist
wenn ich über kasten und kapitalismus
spreche wie ich schon sagte die
unternehmen werden von der kaste der
händler will indiens wirtschaft ist
nicht gewachsen weil wir güter
herstellen wie china
ein großteil des wachstums beruht auf
den bergbau wir können etwas verkaufen
was wir nicht kaufen müssen
der traum jedes geschäft das führt aber
dazu dass der grundwasserspiegel sinkt
die flüsse trocknen aus ob nicht wir
haben eine bevölkerung die auf dem land
vom boden liegt
das bedeutet wir haben eine land
wirtschaftskrise in allen bereichen
kommt es zur erschütterung und
gleichwohl ist indien ein land das über
eine bemerkenswerte bandbreite an
gesinnungen und weisheit verfügt das ist
ein land in dem die menschen immer noch
nicht alle gleichgeschaltet
wo sie noch nicht die gleichen
konsumorientierten träume haben die
sonst über die geschichten die zeigen
sie auch in ihren büchern gerade die
geschichten von globalisierungs
verlieren
nach einer statistik für die in 80
prozent der indischen bevölkerung
weniger als zwei dollar am tag das
frappierend trotz dieses wachstums trotz
dieser reiche die mich interessiert zum
schluss wie sehen die zukunft ihres
landes
ich bin sehr besorgt
vor allem was die nächsten zwei jahre an
belangen weil das flugzeug in dem die
neue mittelklasse platz genommen hat um
abzuheben voller begeisterung
dieses flugzeug ist mitten in der luft
eingefroren und die begeisterung die
beschleunigung haben sich in panik und
wut verwandelt diese wut ist heute gegen
muslims und da lebt gerichtet gegen
atheisten oder marxisten oder wen auch
immer wir haben noch zwei jahre bis zu
den nächsten
ich weiß nicht ob sie von der d
monetarisierung gehört haben als letztes
jahr plötzlich 80 prozent des bargelds
als illegal erklärt wurde
das hat zu den aktuellen zahlen zu einem
drastischen rückgang der arbeitsplätze
und sogar der wachstumsrate die einzige
möglichkeit wie dieses system sich in
den nächsten wahlen an der macht halten
kann ist unfrieden zu stiften
die leute zu polarisieren die feuer
wieder anzuzünden
entweder durch krieg oder konflikte
zwischen volksgruppen
man kann die bedrohliche atmosphäre
schon spüren die sich aufbaut
das beunruhigt mich außerordentlich
die opposition wurde dezimiert das ist
das erste mal dass man das gefühl hat
wir treten in ein zeitalter ein
dass wir nicht völlig verstehen und das
noch nie da war ich hoffe dass sie die
hoffnung nicht verlieren trotz all
dieser missstände und der schwierigen
situation in indien und dass sie
weiterhin so schöne bücher schreiben und
es ist vielen dank für das gespräch und
tirol nächste woche spricht mein kollege
juri steiner mit stephan eicher
ja sie haben richtig gehört stephan
eicher kommt wirklich was sollten sie
auf keinen fall verpassen
und vor 50 jahren eröffnete emil in
luzern das kleintheater ein grund
zurückzublicken und die schweizer
kunstszene etwas genauer zu betrachten
jetzt gleich in der sternstunde kunst
aus bleiben sie dran und einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]
hallo